With the Lord's help We are going to cover many topics I want to give the list so that they know where we are going
And we where head it in the first part will be an   introduction a very, very brief introduction.
The second part: The end of every believer that Hebrews presents to us,
The end of every believer that Hebrews presents to us.
The third part: The way to reach the end that God has for our lives,
The path to reach the end that God has for our lives.
The fourth: The revelation of Christ in Hebrews,
The revelation of Christ in Hebrews.
The fifth: The prophetic that we find in Hebrews.
The sixth: Some key scriptures.
Some key scriptures
Especially: The Admonishments.